alternate Brian Forte replay Center
Courtney Kirkland and here we go up and
running in charge
Here Comes Tatum
while he has a shot clock it's four
Maneuvers to the top down low another
turnover that's the fourth for the Heat
and a little more than four minutes gone
Lowry has to shoot that
Tatum and Spruce across the lane
smart for the Triple
52 shooting for Boston 53 shooting for
Miami
[Applause]
he can handle in these playoffs
especially on the switches his length is
really bothered him
but that's five offensive rebounds
Boston's not missing much when they do
they get it back and now their defense
again takes over
look at Marcus Smart here great steal
takes the ball Coast to Coast but
Hereford keeps coming he doesn't finally
picked up by Miami with Lowry trying to
accelerate by great lines and Williams
knocks the ball away with a nice
defensive play he has had at least three
threes in every game it's still right
there
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
for 19 Celtic points Rob Williams closed
it Grant Williams defends Stripped Away
by smart on the floor Grant Williams
what defense by Boston Here Comes Tatum
outside smoke cheese
he's the one who started and initiated
the play